quello questo è un paesaggio
conosciuto lo potremo riconoscere tra
1000 e quasi in un paesaggio identitario
per quello che lo possiamo vivere il
proprio vicino a noi e anzi lo
consideriamo proprio così come un
paesaggio unico e questa è di questa
unicità ha parlato poco fa l'assessore
c'è stata anche riconosciuta dall'unesco
che ha voluto proprio attribuire le
dolomiti la nozione di patrimonio
mondiale naturale con un dettaglio
seriale nel senso che è una
distribuzione di ben nove siti partiamo
dalle dolomiti di brenta per arrivare
fino al friuli e questa è l'unità numero
3 che non so è costituito dalle pale di
san martino ma troviamo anche le
dolomiti bellunesi le vette feltrine
insomma un sita particolare che ci
permette di avvicinarsi con curiosità
con voglia di sapere mettere essere
abituati ad esempio nel mondo della
cultura ad avere degli insegnamenti come
quelli delle storie dell'arte che ci
permettono quando giriamo perlessità
d'italia nota che all'estero di
riconoscere perché riconosciamo degli
stilemi delle bifore sappiamo dare delle
date
insomma sappiamo introiettare e fare
nostro e provare piacere e soddisfazione
di conoscere per quello che è stato
detto per le scienze naturali non va
tanto così per la gelosia poi abbiamo
tutti studiate alle medie rocce
sedimentarie se i negozi metamorfiche ti
sta nei fossi l'itinerario fa sì però
insomma ecco allora abbiamo la
possibilità oggi di provare un po di
piacere di conoscere un po di questi
paesaggi perché quando li rincontreremo
avremo delle tracce o perlomeno provo a
stimolare in un po qui insomma sulle
dolomiti alcune alcune cose che sappiamo
ne sappiamo perché abbiamo sentito dire
sono delle scogliere dolomiti che queste
cose bianche beh insomma quando noi
diamo un calcio un software di questo
tipo
pensiamo si su ogni tanto riflettiamo
può essere anche divertente pensare che
questo sotto lo ha visto uniti eau sauro
che sono erano stati degli squali 3 4
volte cinque volte più più grandi degli
squali attuali
il signor è veramente un disastro oppure
quando troviamo rozzo un po come queste
che affiorano oppure come questa e
riconosciamo l'ho trovata lungo sentiero
quindi capita anche a voi vedete queste
popolazioni
questi sono delle ondulazioni di una
spiaggia come quella che la mattina
quando con la marea bassa in adriatico e
si fa una passeggiata e quindi ci dice
qui sarà un'area bassa allora la
zoologia si permette di mettere a
confronto uno sguardo grande quindi
cogliere ad esempio la dimensione e del
paesaggio dolomitico ma i suoi oggetti
si permettono di capire nel dettaglio il
loro funzionamento da quand'è che
conosciamo le dolomiti è stato dentro da
sempre da quando solo una nita negli
anni 80 un pochino più in là nelle
dolomiti vette feltrine ho avuto il
piacere di fare uno scavo di preistoria
dove abbiamo trovato delle sensi che
sono quelle rocce che si schiacciano un
po vetrose e che servono per fare
armature quindi per la giavellotti
oppure coltelli per tagliare la carne
dell'uomo di neanderthal quindi appena
questi territori erano in qualche
maniera frequentabili da un uomo che
sapeva muoversi l'uomo di neanderthal
parliamo di 40.000 anni fa sono state
utilizzate
e stato citato poi colbricon dopo
l'ultima grazie e le età glaciale ma
anche il passo rolle
ma se scendiamo nel bio top attorno a
san martino di castrozza poi in val
gardena è tutto un insieme di
accampamenti di caccia che utilizzati
dai cacciatori preistorici appena dopo
la glaciazione quindi sanno proprio nel
paleolitico quando ancora non era stata
inventata l'agricoltura come appunto è
con il neolitico è avvenuto con i primi
campi scendendo vedrete un bivio che va
verso lusi a leeds e gonzalo still here
di bellamonte ma questo nome castelliere
da dove viene viene perché c'era un
vecchio villaggio ma anche villaggio che
ha terminato
né chiari stato in qualche maniera è
riconosciuto come una ca stella mentre
era proprio un insegnamento
probabilmente permanente ma qui andiamo
a finire nella nella nell'archeologia e
non è il mio argomento da cantello ora
apprendiamo dal punto di vista da
quant'è che chiamiamo le dolomiti
dolomiti è stato giulio cesare
carlomagno non è una cosa molto molto
molto più recente e ci sono alcuni dati
importanti per parlare di dolomiti
iniziamo dal 1789 in una data che era
stato interessante e un nobile francese
di grenoble prato è stata anche
abbastanza brevetto perché è riuscito a
passare da nobile la rivoluzione
francese senza grandi problemi li
girando da queste parti raccoglie
appunto un campione di questa rozza e fa
una prova
solitamente quando voi prendete una
roccia calcarea in se mettete sopra dei
lazzi da cloridrico questa frase un po
come l'adc assenza ero pure come
l'aspirina è crescente
lui fa la prova e non frigia niente
succede nulla se ne torna a grenoble mi
come safari so studi alla fine decide
che questa una rozza nuova non era così
presuntuoso da dire la chiamo doroni te
perché mi chiamo diodati e dolori e ma
solo 23 anni dopo un'altra persona suo
collega per farli l'onore di se questa
rozza d'ora in poi le camere mo dovute
però anche chi non ci siamo ancora con
il nome delle dolomiti
in realtà i nomi delle dolomiti è un
affare di marketing che non sa fare
turismo è un affare di guide turistiche
mi spiego meglio dopo la scoperta di
tirate per niente verso l'inizio
dell'ottocento parlo del 1830 anni 137
falbo un nobile tedesco con la passione
nara anche un geologo viene per una
sorta di proto turismo dolomiti con
somma da queste parti per fare il suo
studi di geologia e incomincia a trovare
cose strane voi avete intuito sto
semplificando molto le cose quindi oggi
non abbiamo tempo di entrare nel
dettaglio
comunque riconosce delle particolarità
che lo incuriosiscono molto in condotta
scrivere e scrive soprattutto alla
persona
piuttosto importante a berlino e un
russiano alexander von un bot
era una persona molto importante allora
si parla della prima metà dell'ottocento
non solo era porziano e quindi un
soldato ma era anche diventato un
geologo un naturalista anzi si disse che
le scienze naturali moderne di fatto e
anche l'organizzazione dell'università
scientifica dipende da fon
un bot allora si diceva addirittura che
la prossima più famosa la persona più
famosa dopo napoleone ed effettivamente
ancora oggi in università di berlino è
intestata a un bol
insomma lui essendo un buon agente di
comunicazione fa sì che questo
territorio come stato affrontato da
geologi ricercatori c'è tra quanto siamo
siamo nella prima metà dell'ottocento
sta nascendo questo grande movimento del
romanticismo un romanticismo che dava la
natura un valore estetico valore morale
un valore importante ecco che allora non
si muovono soltanto gli scienziati si
muovono anche gli artisti poeti e quindi
nasce una sensibilità rispetto all
orrore che le montagne prima suscitavano
dal medioevo al rinascimento
anzi durante i primi grand tour no ai
nobili che scegliamo in italia in
carrozza passavano velocissimamente
attraverso le alpi ma ancora si
segnavano di formarsi le montagne
viceversa inizia questo sentimento di
bellezza contaminata e qui abbiamo il
primo lonely planet del 1830 38 43
adesso faccio confusione e è proprio un
blu ray e book
il primo libretto che ti racconta come
fare turismo sulle alpi e poi un'altra
guida importante pochi anni dopo e di dj
set e un altro suo collega che
finalmente dice mount e dolomiti manta
quindi le dolomites mountains nascono
come un bed hecker con un libretto
turistico nella prima metà
dell'ottocento
detto questo
c'è da dire che poi questa storia che
mette assieme a ricerca scientifica
esperienza estetica l'inizio
dell'alpinismo
è la storia bella delle loro menti che
mette assieme questi diversi aspetti
come accogliere che la diversità degli
approcci sappiamo quanto sia importante
la diversità oggi non solo la
biodiversità non solo la biodiversità
come vedremo dopo
ma anche le diversità culturali
solitamente portano buoni soldati ma
direi che possiamo tornare proprio alle
nostre dolomiti
insomma ci sono un paio di cose che
vorrei mettere a fuoco sul discorso
dolomitico noi sappiamo è stato detto e
atolli corallini no più o meno di
coralli cosa sono fuori in realtà sono
perlopiù delle alghe calcaree sono delle
costruzioni che andando al mare ogni
tanto su disco di vediamo oppure chi ha
fatto di viaggi appunto un pot esotici
ha potuto esplorare facendo snorkeling
che tipicamente e vivono in quella zona
da zero o dal livello superiore della
marea fino a circa 20 metri sotto il
livello del mare
fin dove arriva l'acqua sotto poi in
auto buio e quindi hanno una loro vita
in questo spazio
beh c'è qualcosa che non va qua vedo
1500 metri di sta roba
com'è che funziona il pin di 20 metri se
la facciano gli altri come li mette poi
ce li ho su 2.000 metri che
effettivamente movimenti tellurici come
per questa questione
dobbiamo andare a parlare di tettonica
delle placche
insomma è un oggetto scientifica molto
ampio molto discusso in un posto certo
parlare per esteso però di fatto cosa
succede noi abbiamo una terra con queste
placche che in qualche maniera si
muovono suprema e com'è che si muovono
perché sotto c'è un guscio c'è un
mantello un po più viscoso e queste cose
si muove i geologi stanno guardando alla
luna per trovare la soluzione pari noi
siamo abituati alle maree del mare ma
anche le maree del del globo terrestre
si spostano e non ce ne accorgiamo non
sono almeno 20 30 metri al giorno che
vanno su e giù poi ci mette attorno alla
rotazione l'effetto della rotazione
della lunga attorno a questo carrozzone
del pianeta terra e pare che insomma la
mentre tonica del plugin sia dovuta ai
movimenti anche indotti dal passato
terna per quello che ci interessano e
parata ci sono due movimenti
fondamentali quello della dorsale medio
oceanica quanto il terreno di nessuno i
due continenti si spostano e si formano
il fallimento questa è tipica situazione
dell'atlantico oppure delle collisioni
quando una placca va sulla tra placa e
la spinge e la montagna di nessuno e che
è stato esempio sono tutte le corriere
andine le rocky mountains e per certi
versi di malaja e le alpi non a caso poi
queste zone sono anche dalle sismiche
dell'academy terremoti n nepal è la
testimonianza importante di questa di
fatto noi abbiamo a che fare con questa
situazione si è creata a partire dalle
date indicate dall'assessore una
situazione in cui se l'altezza dei miei
occhi sono l'altezza del livello del
mare e incominciano a crescere le mie
barriere coralline sei una che scende un
pochino pian pianino perché a sul bordo
di un oceano che si sta aprendo
ma chiesa così pian pianino che il
chianti continuano a crescere le cretico
dire continuano a crescere
altri invece per motivi legati a zolle
che cedono piu velocemente scende più
velocemente
allora questa che scende lentamente
continua a crescere e l'altezza di negli
occhi continuerò avere le mie scogliere
quest'altra invece sprofonda di più e in
questo sprofondamento di più a bros
sedimenti di altro tipo importante
tipicamente sedimenti meno tenaci meno
compatti di questo allora cosa succederà
che quando inverto il movimento avrò le
montagne che salgono avrà dei
comportamenti diversi ed ecco che
andremo a vedere come mai il latemar il
catenaccio e queste montagne si
presentino con forma quasi di atollo in
una situazione più ondulata un minuto
allora vado via velocissimo sulla storia
la sequenza anche per chi è veramente un
libro aperto
voi siete saliti avete avuto sul lato
destro della catena del lagorai
e questi sono i porti di sumatra le rose
antiche che noi abbiamo che si sono
appoggiati su dei continenti precedenti
incomincia a questa subsidenza che sta
abbassamento e vedete di tutte quelle
righe sugli sterrati sono degli strati
di mare poco profondo
gli ho fatto vedere prima per la roccia
rossa ci sono mai state poi inizia un po
alla volta la deposizione di queste
bancate carbonatiche e questa cosa va da
300 mila anni fino a circa 50 milioni
300 milioni di anni fino a circa 50
milioni fa alla fine qua sopra
anzi qua sotto perché era un livello del
mare abbiamo un oceano profondo 300
metri praticamente non ho tempo di
raccontare di come sarà aperto 10 si
stava chiudendo un oceano sarà l'africa
che premeva chiudeva un mediterraneo che
poi è cominciato a spingere le rocce
sottostanti ha formato dei pennini e le
alpi
cosa succede a quel momento da siglata
milioni 30 mila anni fa crescono le alpi
emergono queste rocce le rocce molto
dure tenace compatte salgono mentre
tutto attorno alle rocce più fragili
vengono erose più facilmente anzi
vengono così e rose che può succedere un
po come di scogliere di dover se lo
scalzamento alla base la
verticalizzazione quindi il nostro
paesaggio caratteristico dolomitico è
dovuto proprio dal contrasto tra le
rocce chiare e sono queste scogliere le
rocce più scure che sono rozzi di mare
profondo sono i vulcani le grandi
praterie che rappresentano proprio
questo tipo di roccia di grandi praterie
questa zia diversità un aspetto molto
importante
e importante poterlo leggere ovunque noi
andremo troveremo tratti di questo
discorso si piace saperne di più c'è un
bellissimo museo che ha aperto a
ferragosto predazzo el'uso delle doc
geologico delle limited predazzo e
aperto anche oggi se volete verso il
ritorno
grazie mille dello stato insieme
no